okay obviously the entire world right
now is talking about the same thing
which is the Charlie Hebdo terrorist
attack in France 12 employees of the
magazine a satirical magazine basically
sort of like the equivalent of the onion
here in America for France were killed
it sounds like three attackers literally
just a second ago I saw that it sounds
like they may have been caught but let's
not get bogged down in the minutia of
exactly what's happening but this is an
incredible an incredible assault on free
speech and freedom of expression now
obviously in America here we have the
First Amendment protecting our free
speech it's a little different in Europe
they have different rights to free
speech there's certain things that they
can't do that we can do here but this is
something that the entire world has to
rally around this is not about religion
this is not about you know bigotry or
any of this other nonsense and I know
how everybody likes to frame everything
now this is simply freedom of expression
and should a free society be allowed to
truly be free nobody is forcing anyone
to live in a free society if you don't
like what's happening in an free society
then go live somewhere else where your
ideals are upheld more you don't have to
live in France if you don't like France
the idea that we are going to
self-censor
and when I say we I mean City citizens
of countries in the West the idea that
we're going to self-censor
right now the AAP is not showing the
cartoons I just tweeted a CNN internal
memo they're not showing the cartoons I
did just see that actually Huffington
Post is showing the cartoons it's not
about inflaming people it's not about
intentionally trying to get people angry
but sorry freedom comes with a cost we
don't have the freedom to not be
offended and people really need to
understand that so this is something
where something horrible has happened
here and it is still unfolding god only
knows what the next couple days are
going to are going to be like in France
and around the world because I think
this is just sort of the only the
beginning of it but something that I did
see that i think is actually kind of
inspiring especially in the
Twittersphere and the little online
digital world is that people are finally
waking up enough of this [ __ ] this is
not about bigotry or hating a religion
or anything like that this is about
freedom of expression it is simple
the most important thing that we have as
human beings it is what separates us
from the animals and we've got to use it
and it is not something that we can give
up